So, now we've looked at 2D
linear transformations.
Let's look at that in a little
bit of an interesting way.
Here's my equation.
We know how to look at that.
Of course we basically talked that
now a simple way to do would be is,
in this case,
I can come up with four parameters.
And sometimes, for example,
a could be the scale and y, and
d could be the scale.
The for example, the numbers
negative kind of give it a flip not.
And similarly, things like c and
b kind of give it the share information.
And again, mixtures of this with sines
and cosines tell us how to do rotations.
So one interesting to note is all
that this means is we are only
look at linear combinations
of these parameters to
generate a newer set of x and
ys, given an x and y.
So x and y, x prime, y prime
are computed knowing what x and y are,
and again if I know the parameters a,
b, c, d.
Let's look at some of the features or
the kind of the details of what
these types of things for y.
They can be used to
generate scaling of images,
rotation of images, shear and
of course also mirroring.
We've looked at all of them so far.
Now let's look at some properties
of these linear transformations.
One thing to note is all of the time
the origin still remains where it is at
0, 0.
We haven't actually done so
far any translation, for example, right?
I gave you this example of looking at
these matrices where we just played
around with how to change them to
do scaling, rotation, shear, scale.
We haven't actually done translation,
so origin remains where it is, always.
Second thing to note in all of this
would be that lines would actually
generate lines again.
So if the image had a line,
same straight line would actually be
generated in the new image,
even with scaling.
Of course, it might look different
in terms of it might be stretched
because we may have stretched
the image more in y and less in x or
something like that, or it might
get flipped when I do the mirror.
But, it still appear as a straight line.
All parallel lines,
because of the fact that everything
is straight line, will also appear.
As a parallel in the new image.
And all ratios would actually be
preserved, as much as possible,
in that image.